[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute bin ich in der Küche.
Mal wirklich eine Premiere: sonntags!
Ich darf hier nur die billigen Rezepte machen,
die unter der Woche sind.
Die Sonntagsrezepte sind dann für die Königin,
für die Grande Madame – die Sally.
Wie gesagt, heute ist Muttertag.
Am Muttertag sollte die Mutter nicht in der Küche stehen.
An allen anderen Tagen ist in Ordnung,
aber nicht an Muttertag, okay?
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Kommen wir zurück zum Muttertag.
Muttertag ist ein Tag...
Der Muttertag hat 1970 angefangen.
Da gab es eine Bewegung: Mother’s Day.
Da haben sich viele Mütter zusammengeschlossen, weil...
Vor 1870, Entschuldigung. 1870 gab’s keine Mütter.
Davor waren Mütter wie Gegenstände, z. B. Stuhl, Stein oder ein Brett.
Dann kam 1870 die Bewegung.
Das war eine Bewegung, wo sich einfach Mütter mal austauschen wollten.
Da haben sie sich getroffen und dann ging es weiter.
Dann hieß es plötzlich:
Die Mütter haben sich dagegen gewehrt,
dass ihre Kinder im Krieg fallen oder in den Krieg gehen müssen.
Da gab es dann diese Muttertagsbewegung.
Sie wurde dann immer größer.
Irgendwann, 1907, hat die Tochter der Gründerin
viele Politiker in den USA angeschrieben.
Dann wurde der zweite Maitag, also zweite Woche sonntags, Mai...
Ihr wisst ganz genau, wie ich das meine!
... wurde dieser Muttertag gegründet,
zum Gedenken an ihre Mutter, die damals schon verstorben war.
Also die Mutter, die 1870 diesen Muttertag
oder diese Bewegung gestartet hat.
Ich bin auch durcheinander, ich weiß! Aber nicht schlimm.
Dann geht’s weiter:
1907 war dann offiziell der Muttertag.
1920 kam es dann nach Deutschland.
Dann haben sich die Blumengeschäfte gedacht:
Cool, wir müssen den Müttern auch Blumen geben und an sie denken.
Dann wurde alles kommerzialisiert.
Die Dame, die 1907 den Muttertag gegründet hat,
hat gesagt: So etwas wollte sie eigentlich gar nicht
- dass es so kommerzialisiert wird.
Dann hat sie alles versucht, dass der Muttertag wieder abgeschafft
wird – ja, die Alte!
Jetzt ist der Muttertag trotzdem geblieben.
Er wurde total kommerzialisiert.
Wir feiern einmal im Jahr Muttertag.
Das heißt, einmal im Jahr ist die Mutter nicht in der Küche.
Muttertag, ja!
Auf jeden Fall finde ich es auch sehr kommerzialisiert,
aber ich denke jeden Tag an meine Mutter
und meine Mutter denkt jeden Tag an mich.
Sie ruft mich auch jeden Tag an
und sagt mir, was ich falsch gemacht habe im Leben.
Ist halt so, ja!
Auf jeden Fall feiert eure Mütter! Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Schenkt ihnen Blumen, Nelken – irgendetwas könnt ihr machen!
Ich backe für meine Mutter.
Nicht für meine Mutter, sondern für meine Frau.
Ich darf sie nicht Mutter nennen,
denn sonst denkt sie, sie wäre alt.
Ich backe für meine Frau Sally einfach einen Kuchen.
Normalerweise wären meine Kinder dabei, aber sie sind auch nicht da.
Deswegen muss ich alles selber machen.
Ich mache es ganz, ganz einfach:
Ich mache einen Muttertagskuchen als No-bake, genau.
Also No-bake heißt, es kriegt jeder hin.
Ich krieg’s hin, du kriegst‘s hin, der Hund kriegt’s hin,
Güni kriegt’s hin, alle kriegen’s hin.
Das ist ein Erdbeer-Mango No-bake-Kuchen.
Ich finde ihn von der Farbe her sehr, sehr genial,
sehr einfach zu machen.
Ich bin, wenn ich das so sagen darf, der Gott des No-bake-Kuchens.
Deswegen mache ich ihn jetzt.
Die Zutaten sind auch ganz, ganz einfach.
Diese habt ihr 100 % zu Hause; es ist gerade Mai.
Also ihr braucht nicht zu denken, dass es Januar ist
und ich drehe die Videos so weit vor, dass jetzt Ding ist.
Es ist wirklich Mai. Es ist heute Muttertag
und ich habe hier Erdbeeren.
Die Erdbeeren sind von unserem Bauer Klaus aus Reilingen.
Props gehen raus an Bauer Klaus.
Bevor ich jetzt anfange...
Ich habe jetzt so viel und mich um Kopf und Kragen geredet.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich jetzt irgendwelche Briefe von Feministinnen
oder irgendwelchen...
keine Ahnung, ich kriege dauernd Briefe.
Ich lese sie aber nicht, weil ich nicht lesen kann.
Auf jeden Fall wollte ich euch sagen,
dass meine Frau nachher beim ZDF-Fernsehgarten ist.
Wahnsinn, oder? Ich darf das gerade ankündigen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr nachher Zeit habt,
könnt ihr ZDF-Fernsehgarten gucken, und zwar mit meiner Frau,
gerade live, und ich bin auch dort.
Wie ich das hinkriege, weiß ich nicht,
aber ich fahre jetzt gleich nach dem Kuchen los nach Mainz
und bin im ZDF-Fernsehgarten.
Könnt ihr mich anschauen oder meine Frau.
Also schaltet ein. Und zwar: Mit dem Zweiten sieht man besser!
[Doing] Heißt der Spruch so, Josh?
JOSH: Ja.
MURAT: Macht man dann so?
Mit dem Zweiten sieht man besser,
ZDF-Fernsehgarten, der Tanz der Mumie.
Das war Spaß! ZDF-Fernsehgarten mag ich; ist lustig, wirklich.
Schaut euch das an!
JOSH: Eh, Murat, Muttertag ist nächste Woche, nicht heute.
MURAT: Ach Muttertag ist nächste Woche?
Ja, habe ich verpeilt.
09. Mai ist Muttertag.
Das heißt, Sally ist erst nächste Woche im ZDF-Fernsehgarten.
Könnt trotzdem zuschauen.
Auf jeden Fall schaltet ein beim ZDF:
Mit dem Zweiten sieht man besser.
Wie gesagt, man darf jetzt noch nicht gratulieren.
Ich gratuliere euch allen zusammen am 09. Mai.
Fangen wir an mit dem Kuchen.
Tut mir leid, das war schon genug.
Karriere schon total am Ende
– sehe ich morgen schon in der Bild-Zeitung. Alles gehatet.
So, fangen wir an! Wir brauchen ganz, ganz einfache Zutaten,
und zwar brauchen wir Leibniz Butterkekse.
Wenn ihr keine Leibniz Butterkekse habt
- die sind übrigens echt mit 42 Zähnen.
Wenn ihr 43 Zähne habt, sind es die Nachgemachten aus dem Lidl.
Könnt ihr auch nehmen, schmecken genauso gut.
Da brauchen wir 250 g Kekse, richtig?
JOSH: 220 g.
MURAT: 220 g waren es. Genau.
220 g Butterkekse. Dann brauchen wir 220 g Butter. [Doing]
JOSH: 150 g.
MURAT: Nein, auch falsch. Warte, ganz kurz.
Ich komme gleich wieder. Ich muss mich kurz sortieren.
Ich habe gerade Angst, dass ich einen Fehler gemacht habe.
Ich komme gleich wieder. Einen Moment!
Okay, warte. Kannst du noch kleiner machen?
Weil ich bin großsichtig.
Also für den Boden brauchen wir 220 g Vollkorn Butterkekse
von Leibniz oder von Lidl.
Dann haben wir 150 g Butter, 450 g Frischkäse Doppelstufe,
250 g Sahne, 150 g Puderzucker, 1 EL Vanilleextrakt
- ihr könnt auch mehr nehmen, dann verkaufen wir auch mehr,
je nachdem, was ihr wollt -,
7 TL San-apart aus Günzburg der Firma Küchle
- Props gehen raus an Küchle -,
1/2 Mango geschält und gewürfelt, 100 g Erdbeeren vom Bauer Klaus
- es funktioniert wirklich nur mit den Erdbeeren vom Bauer Klaus;
andere Erdbeeren funktionieren wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also wir fangen jetzt gleich mit dem einfachsten an:
Das ist der Boden.
Wir nehmen einfach die Butter, tun sie in die Emaille Schale
und schmelzen sie.
Schmelzen heißt nicht anbrennen. Ganz, ganz wichtig!
Während Butter schmilzt, nehmen wir die Leibniz Butterkekse
oder die vom Lidl, je nachdem, was Ihr macht,
tun sie da rein in den 3600 Speedwing Pro von Gefu,
und zwar wie ein Rasenmäher: Zack, zack, zack.
Oh, aua!
[Musik]
Dann haben wir Keksmehl.
Die zerbröselten Kekse macht ihr einfach hier in die Schale hinein.
Wenn ihr den 3600 Speedwing Pro von Gefu nicht habt,
könnt ihr es natürlich auch in ein Küchentuch rollen
und dann mit dem Hammer, Klotz oder Glas draufhauen, wie auch immer,
oder in den Mixer hineingeben – wie ihr wollt.
Aber für mich ist es gleich... kennt ihr das Ding?
Genial! Das macht das Kätzchen.
So, jetzt haben wir die Kekse fertig.
Jawoll!
Jetzt die Butter, die schmilzt.
Ihr seht, Emaille funktioniert auf Induktion.
Ganz cool, wenn man eine Rührschüssel hat,
die man auch gleichzeitig erhitzen kann.
Jetzt erhitzen wir gerade die Butter, dass sie schön flüssig wird.
Wirklich nur auf mittlerer Stufe.
Okay, die Butter ist natürlich ein Geschmacksträger
und macht, dass der Kuchen gesund wird.
[Doing] Wir müssen fett werden.
Natürlich hält die Butter den Keksboden nachher zusammen,
weil es ist ein No-bake-Kuchen. Das heißt, er wird ja nicht erhitzt.
Irgendetwas müssen wir haben, das die Kekse nachher zusammenhält.
Natürlich hätten wir es auch wie bei der Rügenwalder machen können,
hätten Methylcellulose nehmen können,
aber leider habe ich im Garten nichts gefunden.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Butter und tun sie einfach hier rein.
Jetzt müssen wir schnell sein,
bevor sie wieder erkaltet oder erstarrt.
Jetzt tun wir hier komplett die Kekse mit dieser Butter
zu einer homogenen Masse verrühren.
Homogene Masse ist, wenn alles gleichmäßig ist.
Das habe ich einmal irgendwo in einem Kochvideo gehört
oder Backvideo von meiner Frau.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr daheim allein seid, könnt ihr natürlich die Hände benutzen,
aber mir schauen jetzt gerade halb Deutschland zu.
Deswegen benutze ich hier so einen Schaber.
Ist ja ein No-bake-Kuchen.
Das heißt, wir möchten keine Viren oder Bakterien übertragen.
Deswegen alles schön...
Wenn ich jetzt Jamie Oliver wäre, würde ich jetzt einmal reinfassen,
würde nochmal in die Haare gehen und nochmal rein.
Das mache ich aber nicht.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr daheim seid und euch keiner zuschaut,
könnt ihr auch eure Hände nehmen.
Ihr müsst eure Hände auch nicht mehr waschen.
Dann habe ich hier einen Tortenretter.
Unter dem Tortenretter habe ich eine Silikonunterlage.
Die klebt hier fest – keine Ahnung, warum.
Mache ich drauf, ist richtig fest.
Dann nehme ich die Dauerbackfolie.
Ihr könnt auch Backpapier nehmen, wenn ihr keine Dauerbackfolie habt.
Auf die Dauerbackfolie tu ich meinen verstellbaren Tortenring.
Zack, verstellbar in alle Größen. Wahnsinn!
Tu ich den Tortenring hier drauf.
Jetzt nehme ich meine Keksbodenmasse und tu sie einfach hier rein.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich die Keksbodenmasse hier drin.
Jetzt könnt ihr Folgendes machen: Jetzt könnt ihr entweder...
Wenn ich das nicht filmen würde,
würde ich jetzt mit der Hand reingehen
und den Keksboden runterdrücken und mit den Händen zur Seite.
Aber mir schaut ja halb Deutschland zum Muttertag zu.
[Werbemusik] Nehme hier den Gefu Classic 2700 Pro.
Das ist ein Keramik-Patty zum Pattys-Machen,
also wenn ihr Burger macht.
Oder um Keksböden runterzudrücken.
Ich drücke den Keksboden jetzt hier runter
und drücke ihn gleichzeitig an den Rand, damit nachher
der Cheesecake oder dieser No-bake Cake einen kleinen Rand hat.
Wenn ihr diesen 3600 Pro von Gefu nicht habt,
könnt ihr auch ein Glas nehmen.
Ein Glas nehmen und dann seitlich so hindrücken.
Josh, filme mal bitte kurz rein,
damit die Zuschauer wissen, wie ich es meine,
weil ich bin irgendwie Erklär-Legastheniker.
Ruhig den Boden fest andrücken und ein bisschen einen Rand formen.
Wenn euer Keksteig zu trocken ist,
habt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig Butter benutzt.
Könnt ihr auch reinmachen, wenn ihr Lust habt.
Ich muss es nicht, weil mein Keksteig ist richtig,
weil es ist ja mein Rezept!
Weiter geht’s. Jetzt tut mir einen Gefallen:
Jetzt nehmt ihr das Ding. Ich weiß zwar nicht wie – ah, so!
Jetzt tun wir es einfach nochmal...
Boah, boah, habt ihr gesehen? Murat: Leben am Limit.
Das tun wir jetzt einfach in den Kühlschrank.
Lasst es etwa 30-60 Minuten komplett abkühlen,
dass die Butter richtig hart und der Keksboden fest wird.
Während der Kuchen abkühlt
- wie gesagt, mindestens 30 Minuten, maximal 60 Minuten –,
machen wir die Füllung für den No-bake Cake.
[Uhr]
Jetzt machen wir die Füllung. Dafür brauchen wir eine KitchenAid.
Ihr könnt auch eine andere Küchenmaschine
oder auch einen Rührstab nehmen.
Bei mir läuft’s halt, deswegen KitchenAid.
Dann nehmen wir hier den Frischkäse mit Doppelrahmstufe.
Ich würde euch da wirklich Doppelrahmstufe empfehlen.
Die gebe ich hier rein.
Habt ihr gemerkt? Deswegen Doppelrahmstufe.
Es kippt dann alles auf einmal rein.
Da haben wir Doppelrahmstufe.
Jetzt mache ich zu und gehe auf Stufe... zack.
Während es rührt, gebe ich den Puderzucker dazu.
Jetzt verrührt es schön den Puderzucker.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Sahne.
Ein bisschen schneller und rühren die Sahne mit hinein.
Eine richtig schöne Sauerei. Warte, wo ist das Ding?
Auskratzen wie meine Frau.
Wenn ich es nicht auskratze, kriege ich voll Ärger.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes: Jetzt nehmen wir San-apart.
San-apart ist ein Sahnesteifmittel,
aber es ist nicht nur zum Sahnesteifen,
sondern um auch Cremes zu steifen.
Und es kommt aus Günzburg, wollte ich nur sagen.
Zack, rein. Und jetzt geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Noch schneller?
Noch schneller? [Explosion]
Jetzt warten wir. Nicht zu lange rühren, weil sonst wird es Butter.
Wenn es Butter wird, dann holt ihr euch einfach ein Brot
und dann könnt ihr es draufschmieren.
Jetzt zeige ich euch einen ganz coolen Trick: Zack, das war’s!
Habt ihr gesehen?
Ihr habt jetzt gesehen, das hat alles nicht einmal 2 Minuten gedauert.
Jetzt nehme ich es hoch.
Jetzt mache ich den Haken sauber. Meine Frau hat so ein Gerät dafür.
Ich weiß, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Sie hat so ein Gerät, um das Ding sauberzumachen.
Meine Frau hat für alles ein Gerät.
Sie hat irgendwelche Dinger, wo da so...
Vielleicht wisst ihr das. Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Bei meiner Frau sieht es auch professioneller aus, wenn sie es macht.
Meine Frau ist halt meine Frau. Die kann das.
Jetzt haben wir das. [Aufschrei]
Habt ihr das gesehen?
JOSH: Ja.
MURAT: Es tut mir leid. [Lacht]
Da müsst ihr wirklich hygienisch sein, weil es ist ein No-bake Cake
und wir wollen ja nicht,
dass nachher eine Pandemie ausbricht - in meiner Küche.
Ihr seht auch, dass alles richtig ist,
wenn die Creme nicht runterkommt. Wahnsinn, oder?
Jetz habt ihr Angst gekriegt. Jetzt habt ihr alle Angst gekriegt,
aber der Murat weiß, was er macht.
Das ist genau die gleiche Masse,
wenn ihr mit Flexkleber die Fliesen an die Wand klebt.
Genauso muss die Masse sein. Ihr seht: zack! Wahnsinn, was?
Kriegt ihr Angst, ihr kriegt alle Angst, aber ich kriege keine Angst.
Ich weiß, was ich mache – ich habe schon einige Baustellen gemacht.
Wie gesagt, die Creme lassen wir jetzt einfach stehen.
Habt da keine Angst, da kann nichts passieren.
Die Küchenmaschine brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr. Boah!
Erstmal gucken, wie das Ding funktioniert.
Rein wieder und dann raus... und weg!
Perfekt. Jetzt räume ich ganz kurz auf und dann geht’s gleich weiter.
Jetzt kommt ja oben auf die Creme so eine coole Mangoschicht drauf.
Deswegen habe ich hier eine Mango, und zwar ist es eine Frucht.
Dann nehme ich dieses Murat-Messer.
Dieses Murat-Messer ist brutal.
Normalerweise ist es nur zum Fleischschneiden,
aber heute mache ich wirklich eine Sensation:
Ich werde damit Früchte schneiden.
Das ist ungefähr so, als würdest du versuchen,
einen Baseballschläger in eine BiFi-Verpackung hineinzudrücken.
Ihr müsst jetzt wirklich einen präzisen Schnitt machen.
Freunde nennen mich auch Dr. Brinkmann.
Jetzt einfach die Mango so hinstellen.
Dann nehmt ihr dieses Murat-Messer.
Ihr dürft jetzt nicht erschrecken.
Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich auf einen harten Knochen treffen.
Das ist kein Knochen, sondern ein Kern.
Ich zeig’s euch ganz kurz.
[Trommelwirbel]
Aha! Aha!
So, bin mal gespannt.
Wo ist der Kern?
Wahnsinn, es ist eine besondere Zucht, die ohne Kern ist.
Ich wollte euch einen Trick zeigen. Jetzt hat er nicht funktioniert.
Was mache ich jetzt? Hmm...
Ja genau, dann geht’s einfach weiter.
Genau, morgen geht’s einfach weiter,
und zwar zeige ich euch einen Trick mit der Schale.
Den hat mir meine Frau mal gezeigt: Da gehst du hier rein
und drücke den dagegen, zack!
Hat auch nicht funktioniert! Ja, Wahnsinn!
Heute geht gar nichts. Heute geht alles schief – egal!
Wisst ihr was, vergesst einfach meinen Trick!
Macht es wie normale, zivilisierte Menschen:
Schneidet die Mango und schält sie einfach.
Ach schade! [Alarm]
Das gibt’s nicht. Das geht nicht.
Ich bring es nicht übers Herz als Schwabe.
Ich schäle sie noch ein bisschen. Guck mal hier!
Wie viel hier noch dran ist, guck mal!
Josh, siehst du das?
Ich bring’s nicht übers Herz.
Das werde ich komplett für den Guss nachher verwenden.
Jetzt gucke ich einfach, wo der Kern der Mango ist.
Da ist normalerweise ein Kern drin.
Aha, ich hab ihn gefunden.
Mein Gott, das ist aber ein komischer Kern.
Den sieht man ja gar nicht.
Auf jeden Fall zeige ich euch noch einen zweiten Trick.
Auch beim Mangoschneiden und er geht auch ganz, ganz einfach.
Der erste hat nicht funktioniert.
Eigentlich funktioniert er, aber ich sollte aufhören,
TikTok-Videos zu schauen.
Und zwar geht er so.
[Musik]
Der ist ungefähr wie Rambo, wenn er eine Mango schneidet.
So, jetzt habe ich hier diese Würfel reingeschnitten.
Jetzt passt mal auf, was ich jetzt mache: Aha! Hat funktioniert.
Bin ich nicht ein wahnsinnig cooler Koch?
Jetzt hole ich mir ein kleines Messer.
Jetzt peele ich hier einfach – seht ihr das? Wie so ein Chirurg.
Jetzt habe ich Ananaswürfel.
Eh, nicht Ananaswürfel, ich meine Mangowürfel.
Seht ihr das? Wahnsinn.
[Musik]
Die Würfel hätte ich noch ein bisschen kleiner schneiden können,
aber wie gesagt, ihr müsst nicht jeden Trick nachmachen,
den ich euch gesagt habe.
Auf die Welt habt ihr es auch allein geschafft
und vor mir konntet ihr wahrscheinlich auch kochen und backen.
Deswegen kleine Würfel schneiden.
Die tu ich nachher in diese Creme hier vorn rein.
Es passiert, dass ein paar Stücke darin sind, ein paar Mangostücke.
Mango schmeckt echt richtig lecker. Ich liebe Mango über alles.
Die Frucht ist aber leider so teuer, finde ich.
Also... klar, eine Südfrucht ist immer teuer, aber ist nicht günstig.
Was ich auch voll mag: Kennt ihr das? Das kann man auch kaufen.
So Mangoleder, getrocknete Mangos.
Boah, das ist so genial. Das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Ich liebe getrocknete Mangos, aber ungezuckert.
Da ist genug Zucker drin.
So, wie gesagt, die Hälfte der Mangos würfeln
und die andere Hälfte der Mangos tut ihr da rein als Püree.
Dann nehme ich noch diese Mango hier noch.
Die habe ich vorher vergessen.
Diesen Teil der Mango...
Eh, ich verwechsle gerade etwas.
Vielleicht haben es manche Zuschauer gemerkt:
Und zwar habe ich gedacht, ich verwechsle die Mango mit einer Avocado
und ich denke mir die ganze Zeit „Wo ist dieser Kern von der Mango“.
Das ist aber eine Avocado.
Also Avocado hat einen Bollen drin.
In einer Mango ist der Kern eigentlich nur hart. Genau!
Hättet ihr mir auch früher sagen können,
dass eine Mango keinen Kern hat.
Und zwar, der ist hart.
Guck, hört ihr das? Das ist holzig.
So. Wir haben es nun aufgeklärt.
Also eine Mango hat keinen runden, sondern einen länglichen Kern.
So, wie gesagt, habe ich ungefähr 250 g Mangos ohne Kern,
den ich jetzt schon weggeschmissen habe.
Das heißt, die Hälfte einmal in Würfel geschnitten.
Die Hälfte ist so. Die brauche ich nachher als Püree.
Dann nehme ich die Erdbeeren von Bauer Klaus aus Reilingen.
Dieses Rezept, ist leider Gottes so,
funktioniert nur mit den Erdbeeren von Bauer Klaus.
Also ihr könnt ihn anrufen: Klaus Schröder heißt er, aus Reilingen.
Das Telefon klingelt, Klaus.
So, dann tut ihr die Erdbeeren natürlich
– ich wollte gerade entkernen sagen –
das Grün wegschneiden.
Dafür hat meine Frau auch ein Gerät, aber ich hab es nicht gefunden.
[Musik]
Die Erdbeeren könnt ihr jetzt
mit dem Murat Knife natürlich in Würfel schneiden.
Also einfach ganz, ganz coole Würfel.
Die werden nachher mit den gewürfelten Mangos
einfach in die Creme reingeschmissen, so als feste Stückchen.
Da ist wirklich mit den Erdbeeren –
wie gesagt, ihr müsst euch nicht an die Grammzahlen halten,
die ich euch angegeben habe. Ihr könnt auch mehr verwenden.
Wenn ihr Lust darauf habt, wenn ihr Erdbeeren ganz arg mögt,
könnt ihr auch mehr nehmen.
Der Bauer Klaus ist übrigens in Reilingen an der Hauptstraße,
wenn ihr daran vorbeifahrt.
Er hat auch sonntags geöffnet, der Bauer Klaus.
[Musik]
So, jetzt nehme ich die Creme
und die in Würfel geschnittenen Erdbeeren und Mangos.
Jetzt heben wir sie unter, also einfach nur kurz zweimal, zack!
Okay, ein drittes Mal mache ich auch nochmal.
[Mit der Stimme von Fahrgeschäften] Jawoll, weiter geht’s.
Eine tolle Runde. Bitte anschnallen.
So, komplett fertig. Das reicht jetzt vollkommen.
Jetzt machen wir diese
- ich würde jetzt sagen, das ist keine Spiegelglasur,
aber nochmal eine Schicht darüber, die so richtig aussieht wie...
Das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Früher gab es mal ein Eis. Das hieß Split.
Kennt ihr das vielleicht noch?
Kennst du noch Split?
Jetzt gibt es einen anderen Namen dafür.
Bolero heißt es jetzt, glaube ich.
AUS DEM HINTERGRUND: Solero.
MURAT: Wie heißt es? Solero!
Ach, Bolero ist ein Hut, glaube ich, oder ein Tanz. Keine Ahnung.
Genau, Solero heißt es.
Früher hieß es Split; war ganz, ganz toll!
Jetzt machen wir diese Schicht auch ganz, ganz easy.
Okay, jetzt machen wir diese Mangoschicht.
Und zwar habe ich hier noch von vorher die Mango.
Die gebe ich hier rein.
Jetzt habe richtig Lust auf etwas, und zwar: Hier!
Damit es besser geht, gebe ich hier den Mangosaft dazu.
[Pürierstab]
[Musik]
Wenn ihr daheim keinen Pürierstab habt, nehmt ihr einfach einen Mixer.
Boah, das riecht so hammermäßig. Ich liebe den Geruch von Mango.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes. Es ist jetzt ganz, ganz wichtig.
Da dürft ihr nicht zu lang und zu kurz machen.
Und zwar drei Minuten lang machen wir Folgendes:
Wir legen hier einen Topf auf den Herd
und erwärmen ihn ungefähr auf mittlere Hitze.
Solange die Flüssigkeit noch kalt ist – sie ist jetzt noch kalt -,
rein, genau.
Schnell rein, solange die Flüssigkeit noch kalt ist.
Jetzt kommt nämlich der Trick:
Jetzt machen wir das Ding nämlich vegan, zumindest die Creme.
Agar Agar – das sind Algen. So, Agar Agar.
Ihr könnt dazu auch Gelatine nehmen. Das müsst ihr aber anders machen.
Jetzt geliert es. Und immer rühren, richtig schön kochen lassen!
Rühren, rühren, rühren, dass es nicht anbrennt!
So, wie gesagt, wenn es kocht,
dann wirklich 3 Minuten lang rühren, rühren, rühren.
Ist jetzt nicht schlimm. 3 Minuten geht. Kriegt ihr hin!
Wenn jetzt die 3 Minuten vorbei sind – sind sie jetzt bei mir -,
einfach wegstellen und abkühlen lassen.
Hier ist es ganz, ganz wichtig,
dass ihr nicht die fertige heiße Creme nachher
über die Torte darüber gebt.
Wirklich kurz abkühlen lassen.
Agar Agar wird wirklich erst fest, wenn es abkühlt.
In der Zwischenzeit, während es abkühlt,
geben wir schon mal die Creme auf den Keksboden.
Jetzt nehme ich die Creme und gebe sie hier komplett rein
und richten – oh!
Und so, genau wie es meine Frau machen würde,
wirklich alles vom Schüsselrand weg.
So, zack!
Und jetzt schön verstreichen.
Jetzt könnt ihr eine Tortenwinkelpalette nehmen,
ist eigentlich ein ganz cooles Ding.
So, jetzt streichen wir die Torte richtig glatt.
Sieht richtig genial aus, jetzt schon!
Jetzt seht ihr auch einmal das ganze Werkzeug:
so ein Ding, das sich dreht, dann so eine Winkelpalette.
Das ergibt schon Sinn.
[Musik]
Also wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich wie das Mauern,
wenn man eine Mauer bauen will oder Fliesen ankleben würde.
Sieht richtig cool aus. Hammer!
Jetzt haben wir dieses hier fertig. Jetzt machen wir noch Folgendes:
Jetzt haben wir die obere Schicht, das heißt, die Gelierschicht.
Da ist ganz, ganz wichtig – ich habe es vorher schon gesagt -,
es muss ein bisschen runtergekühlt werden.
Agar Agar wird wirklich erst hart, wenn es runtergekühlt ist.
Jetzt gucke ich mal ganz kurz – nein, ist noch ein bisschen zu warm!
Da warte ich noch ganz kurz.
Aber wenn wir nachher diese Schicht darüber haben,
möchten wir nach oben ein bisschen garniert haben.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt noch ein paar Erdbeeren da.
Die waren in der Menge nicht mit inbegriffen.
Das könnt ihr auch machen, wenn ihr Lust darauf habt.
Ich hole jetzt noch ein paar Erdbeeren,
dass ich das von oben noch ein bisschen garnieren kann.
[Musik]
So, der Spiegel ist eigentlich schon abgekühlt.
Ein bisschen warm, aber hier ist es ganz, ganz wichtig: Nicht heiß!
Jetzt kippe ich es darüber. Boah, wie genial das aussieht!
Josh, komm mal her!
[Musik]
Man sieht auch, wie es von allein schon verläuft.
Das heißt, ich muss gar nicht viel darüberstreichen.
Es verläuft von allein.
Jetzt gucken wir, dass es auch schön überall am Rand ist.
Jetzt tut mir bitte einen Gefallen:
Jetzt nehmt ihr die Torte
und tut sie noch einmal für 15-30 Minuten in den Kühlschrank,
dass sie ein bisschen abkühlt,
auch das Agar Agar, dass es richtig fest wird.
Wenn wir das gemacht haben, können wir es in 15 Minuten garnieren.
[Uhr]
Also der Spiegel ist jetzt richtig cool abgekühlt.
Jetzt kommt eigentlich... Ich kriege immer Angst, wenn ich das Ding...
Jetzt kannst du theoretisch alles versauen.
Das heißt, die ganze viele Arbeit umsonst.
Aber ich versuche es irgendwie so hinzukriegen,
wie es meine Frau macht.
Also sie macht es so, sie nimmt die Dauerbackfolie
und wickelt sie so ein – irgendwie so macht sie das. Boah!
So, ha ha, ich habe es hingekriegt. Hat funktioniert.
Ihr seht auch: Es hat perfekt funktioniert,
weil sonst wäre hier ein Abdruck vom Boden.
So, jetzt habe ich das gemacht. Jetzt kommt das Nächste.
Jetzt muss ich gerade überlegen. Was mache ich als Nächstes?
Genau.
Ich komme mir gerade so vor wie ein japanischer Gemüsekoch,
aber ich kriege das hin.
Jetzt nehme ich diesen Tortenretter und lege die Torte hier darauf,
schiebe sie da rein und schiebe die Torte hier drauf.
Boah! Okay, hat auch funktioniert.
Jetzt geht’s weiter.
Warte, wir sind noch nicht fertig! Wir sind noch nicht fertig.
Und zwar ist das hier ein Tortenringmesser.
Jetzt nehme ich das Tortenringmesser.
Jetzt dürft ihr einen Fehler nicht machen:
Ihr dürft nicht so machen – zack, zack, zack -,
sondern ihr müsst durchziehen, sonst macht ihr den Boden kaputt.
Ich schiebe ihn jetzt hier rein. Zack!
Und jetzt schiebe ich es durch.
Seht ihr das? Murat ist da eiskalt.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann es sein,
wenn ihr einen Fehler gemacht habt, läuft alles raus.
Wenn ihr keinen Fehler gemacht habt, dann habt ihr eine schöne Torte.
Ich habe es gelöst.
Wahnsinn, oder? Brutal!
Perfekt!
Jetzt haben wir die schöne Mango-Erdbeertorte natürlich fertig.
Die Stücke... Guck mal drauf, Josh! Sieht richtig cool aus.
Guck mal kurz hin.
Jetzt könnt ihr, jetzt macht es nämlich Spaß, kreativ sein.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Torte ein bisschen verzieren.
Da ist meine Frau besser im Verzieren.
Ich habe da nicht die Geduld dazu.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was ich daraus mache.
So, jetzt mache ich noch ein Pentagramm daraus.
Dann würde es richtig Ärger geben.
Oh, ich mache so eine Sonne. Warte kurz, ich mache eine Sonne.
Ich mache eine Sonne! Oh, das sieht toll aus. So!
[Musik]
Jetzt, bevor wir sie anschneiden,
lasse ich die Sarah erst ein Foto schießen.
Wenn das Foto fertig ist, probieren wir mal die Torte,
ob sie wirklich so gut schmeckt, wie sie aussieht.
Natürlich schmeckt sie gut,
sonst hätte ich euch das Rezept nicht gezeigt,
aber wie gesagt, erst fotografieren und dann probieren.
[Musik]
So, ich bin jetzt fertig mit der Torte.
Sie sieht richtig cool aus.
Wenn man wirklich schnell ist,
hat man die Torte in einer Stunde fertig.
Eine halbe Stunde Zubereitungszeit. Okay, nicht ganz.
Eine Stunde Kühlzeit ungefähr.
In eineinhalb Stunden kriegt man das schon hin.
Und ihr seht: ganz, ganz einfach ohne Backen.
Achtet natürlich auf die Hygiene, weil
– wisst ihr Bescheid, was passieren könnte.
Jetzt hole ich die Dame, für die ich das eigentlich gemacht habe,
für meine Frau, für die Mutter meiner Kinder: Sally!
[Jubel] Alles Gute zum Muttertag, Sally.
SALLY: Danke.
MURAT: Auch wenn es erst nächste Woche ist.
SALLY: [Flüstert]
MURAT: Ich weiß, ich wollte es nicht nennen.
Du kannst jetzt Werbung für dich machen,
wenn du schon mal auf meinem Kanal bist.
SALLY: Echt?
MURAT: Weil du ja im...
SALLY: In deinem Schatten stehe?
MURAT: Genau. Weil du ja nächste Woche im ZDF-Fernsehgarten bist.
SALLY: Ja, also nächste Woche bin ich im ZDF-Fernsehgarten.
Da könnt ihr gerne zuschauen.
Da backe ich dann live für euch und mit euch.
Heute gibt es auch noch einen Live-Stream, also heute am 02. Mai.
Da werde ich euch die Zutaten verraten.
Das heißt, ihr könnt dann alle schon einkaufen
und könnt gern live am Muttertag mit mir backen.
Danach gehe ich auch zu meiner Mama und bringe ihr den Kuchen mit.
MURAT: Und das, was du backst, ist einfach,
weil ich habe vorher gesagt
dass die Mütter an dem Tag normalerweise nicht backen sollen,
weil da sollen die Kinder oder die Väter für die Mütter backen.
SALLY: Finde ich auch.
MURAT: Ja, wäre eine coole Geschichte.
Ich habe den Zuschauern heute vieles beigebracht,
woher der Muttertag eigentlich kommt. Die wissen jetzt Bescheid.
SALLY: Sehr gut. Richtig Aufklärungsarbeit.
MURAT: Ja, ich habe da noch etwas im Kühlschrank gefunden,
und zwar hier: Gratuliere Sally.
SALLY: Aber warum Gratulation? Warum nicht „Danke“, „Thank you“, ...
MURAT: Ja, weil du einen so tollen Mann hast.
SALLY: ... „Ich liebe dich“.
MURAT: Ich gratuliere dir, Sally. [Sally lacht]
So, willst du mal probieren?
SALLY: Danke. [Lacht]
MURAT: Ja. Mehr nicht, mehr nicht, bitte nicht.
Meine Mutter guckt zu.
Mein Gott! Nicht so viele Emotionen. Wir sind nicht bei Dallas.
So, dann gehen wir weiter.
SALLY: Bei wo?
MURAT: Wir probieren das jetzt einmal aus.
Ich mache dir jetzt ein Stück Kuchen.
SALLY: [Lacht] Mit dem...
MURAT: Alles klar?
SALLY: Die schöne Torte. Ist das...? Oh mein Gott!
MURAT: Ah ja, ich mache alles, um hier Action reinzubringen.
SALLY: Macht das niemals so. Bitte!
Messer müsst ihr immer so nicht mit der Klinge in die Handfläche.
Oh Gott! Nicht nachmachen! [Murat stimmt zu]
Warum so ein kleines Stück? Setzt du mich auf Diät?
MURAT: Nein, ich muss noch Fotos machen.
SALLY: Ach so. Ich gebe dir auch immer ein ganzes.
MURAT: Ist mir egal. Sally, bitte.
Oh! Oh!
SALLY: Sarah, sieht schlecht aus mit deinen Fotos. [Lacht]
MURAT: Oh Schatz, ich habe irgendetwas falsch gemacht.
[Alle lachen]
Schatz, ich habe irgendetwas falsch gemacht.
Oh, ein Glasdessert. Hättest du damit gerechnet?
[Alle lachen]
Ja, was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht? Kannst du mir das sagen?
SALLY: Du musst nicht mit einem Metzgermesser die Torte anschneiden.
MURAT: Meinst du, es liegt am Messer?
SALLY: Ja! Ich meine, dafür gibt es doch Kuchenheber.
MURAT: Ach ja. Es gibt Kuchenheber bei uns...
SALLY: Und Tortenmesser.
MURAT: ... auch im Shop! Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Guck mal, das ist voll der Hammer! Was geht?!
SALLY: Auch so eins.
MURAT: Die Frau hat für alles ein Messer.
Für jeden Wochentag! Wahnsinn, oder?
Das ist ein Tortenmesser. Sieht aus wie Aladins Säbel. Und das hier.
Macht das bitte nicht mit dem Murat Knife.
Ich wollte einfach nur ‘ne Produktplatzierung für mein Messer machen,
aber macht das bitte nicht mit meinem Messer.
SALLY: Damit kannst du aber Fleisch und so...
MURAT: Okay, ja.
SALLY: Soll ich probieren?
MURAT: Probiere! Bitte, es tut mir voll leid.
Normalerweise passiert das nicht.
SALLY: [Lacht] Ich probiere mit dem Crunch-Boden.
Ich liebe ja Crunch-Böden.
MURAT: Übrigens ist das Leibniz Butterkeks nur original mit den 42 Zähnen.
Wenn es 43 sind...
SALLY: 52!
MURAT: 52? 52 Zähne?
SALLY: Nur echte haben 52.
MURAT: Ah, das waren nur 42. Das waren die vom Lidl.
[Sally lacht]
Und?
SALLY: Mmh!
MURAT: Cool, gell? [Sally stimmt zu]
Diese Mango.
SALLY: Mango-Erdbeere, ja!
MURAT: Ja, passt immer eigentlich. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Richtig gut!
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: Ist voll die Sommertorte.
MURAT: Ja?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Warum? Weil wir Sommer haben. Ja.
Also wirklich nochmal alles, alles Gute zum Muttertag.
Heute ist dein Tag. Also nicht heute, sondern nächste Woche.
Wie gesagt, an den anderen 355 Tagen
stehst du dann wieder in der Küche.
War ein Spaß!
SALLY: Danke fürs Backen!
MURAT: Gerne!
SALLY: Die ist voll schön und richtig lecker.
MURAT: Ich habe sie eigentlich nicht gebacken,
weil es ja ein No-bake ist.
SALLY: Danke fürs Nichtbacken.
Die ist richtig schön. [Murat stimmt zu]
Komm, das kriegen wir zusammen noch hin.
Wir schneiden jetzt noch ein schönes Stück raus.
Dann hast du auch schöne Bilder.
MURAT: Kann es auch daran liegen, dass ich sie zu wenig gekühlt habe?
SALLY: Nein.
MURAT: Hat echt mit dem Messer zu tun, gell?
SALLY: Ja, weil guck mal! Wenn sie jetzt zu wenig gekühlt wäre,
wäre sie jetzt hier drinnen auch zusammengefallen.
Aber sie ist ja schön standfest. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Mmh!
SALLY: Die ist richtig gut, gell?
MURAT: Die ist auch nicht zu süß, gell?
SALLY: Ich finde sie perfekt.
Vor allem die Erdbeeren werden jetzt noch richtig reif
jetzt mit der Saison. Das wird. Ich finde sie super!
Macht es genauso nach.
Ich hätte vielleicht nur... Nein, ich sage es nicht.
MURAT: Hammer!
SALLY: Hast du eine Sonne dekoriert? [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Schmeckt echt Hammer! Und auch die obere Schicht.
SALLY: Ich glaube, ich würde... Ich will echt keine...
Doch, ich übe Kritik aus. Du kritisierst mich auch immer.
Ich würde die Erdbeeren als Kranz darauflegen.
Aber ich finde das Herz voll süß.
MURAT: Boah! Das schmeckt echt hammermäßig.
SALLY: Gratuliere Murat zum wunderschönen Kuchen.
MURAT: Hammer!
Boah! Der schmeckt richtig lecker!
SALLY: Ich muss sagen, du hast echt einen guten Geschmack, ...
MURAT: Ja?
SALLY: ... was Frauen betrifft
[Beide lachen]
und was Tortenrezepte angeht.
MURAT: Hammer!
SALLY: Echt gut. Ich muss dich beglückwünschen.
MURAT: Macht das nach!
[Sally lacht]
Abonniert den Kanal. Macht einen Kommentar.
Obwohl, es ist nicht mein Kanal; ist dein Kanal.
Ihr könnt auch mir auf Instagram folgen: @der_murat_
Okay, abonniert dieses Kanal auch!
Tschüss, macht’s gut!
SALLY: Ich habe gedacht, du kommst jetzt gar nicht mehr zum Ende.
MURAT: Ja, viel Spaß.
SALLY: Oh, danke! Tschüss!
MURAT: Grüße an alle Mütter gehen raus.
Einen ganz, ganz schönen Muttertag wünsche ich euch.
[Musik]